this is what we one of the things we
talked about with uh one of the things
we talked about alex jones the other day
was
i think we talked about on the show the
the chicken analogy i like to use i
don't know if it was on the bone i think
it was on the bonus segment prep so
people are getting
we'll tell you the story and then i like
to hear thoughts on this so you know
alex likes to talk about the globalists
and uh depopulation and the the one
world and all the stuff
and i said
you know what if it's true that we're
overpopulating and like yeast in a
bottle we're consuming the sugars and
farting ourselves to death
and so
when we talk about any kind of these
conspiracies here's what i say
imagine you have 10 chickens and
chickens like to take dumps in their
water you know firsthand every morning
when i clean out the water i'm like why
do you keep doing this
because sometimes i feel like it's on
purpose and they're smarter than i think
but no no look
they're smart enough to realize not to
drink the crap water but not smart
enough to realize not to crap in it
they're the ones now imagine you had 10
chickens and they all keep crapping in
the water so you go in one day and you
do something to train them stop doing it
the next day five of them stopped and
five of them keep doing it yeah are you
which what which chicken
which chickens do you want to breed yeah
exactly not the ones that keep crapping
in their water so i bring that because
you talk about the activists the
environmentalists the the ban climate
you know uh ban fossil fuels and climate
change and all stuff those are the
people in cities who are the chickens
crapping in their own water
while they're being told to stop doing
it and they keep doing it at a certain
point someone's going to be like i'm not
going to choose to put resources into
those communities that keep crapping in
their water and destroying everything i
would rather invest in communities that
are more self-sustaining guess what it
ain't in the cities
so it's like you were saying these
people are saying i want to ban all
fossil fuels but i need 17 variety of
orange juice based on my pulp
consumption yeah
and we peanut butter everything um bread
and we see that growth of of rural
america i mean there is things are
starting to shift suburbs are becoming
which is why there is a big push to end
suburbia heck gavin newsom the day after
he won re-election changed uh zoning
laws in california to ban single house
uh dwelling zoning laws right
neighborhoods that you could only build
a single family house that's no longer
gone because that's that's they have to
get rid of that shift they need people
concentrated in the cities because that
concentrates their power but people who
are able to a lot of them are going to
other states or just like i did left i
mean
18 years in new york 20 years in dc and
and now i live in the middle of the
country because i wanted to get the hell
away from those policies you want to be
an environmentalist make a homestead
yeah grow grow as much of your own food
as possible tend to your own garden i
mean look if you've got a septic system
in a lot of ways they're very
self-sufficient you do have to get them
pumped but done right
that they the bacteria can take care of
things for you plus you get well water
you can get some kind of you can get
renewable energy sources to offset your
energy costs and even remove yourself
from the grid yet you go to these cities
and they're the most wasteful
they
like the air conditioning cost for some
of these cities is so absolutely insane
because they're completely inefficient
it's and i don't know if you guys you
guys have been in new york you ever see
those big nitrogen tanks they have where
they're blasting nitrogen underground
and and the vapor is coming up from the
ground i think it's nitrogen what i was
told and i fact check man this one
because i did this was just scuttle but
i heard from like a local guy in new
york is that the underground cable
infrastructure is so old it's
overheating and melting so they just
wheel in big tanks of nitrogen to blast
nitrogen to cool it off and they yeah
they blast it to cool the cable so they
don't melt wow you've got infrastructure
so old and decayed that we are wasting
ridiculous amounts of energy to sustain
this system and we keep building on top
of it
those are the people that are voting
nationally to implement rules on west
virginians who have like very little
carbon footprint and tend to their own
chickens and goats and grow their own
corn or whatever they're the people who
will and i know friends who have done
this and i do make fun of them so i
apologize if anyone listening is that
person they are the people who will
postmates a bagel at 9am to their house
and they will talk about sustainability
and you said you know how many fossil
fuels you just how much waste there is
that you couldn't either walk yourself
or just you didn't buy bread and make
your own little toaster
but i really wanted they have really
good bagels in this one place and they
will spend eight i know people who have
spent up to eighteen dollars for like a
bagel with cream cheese because that's
just what they wanted for breakfast so
it's like you're gonna abolish fossil
fuels it's like wall-e you know the big
fat people sitting in the chairs oh yeah
yeah i i i know the story about
post-mating the bagels man i've seen in
in new york people being like i've
ordered a tea
i've seen people order a bubble tea and
i'm like you had someone come on that
like little electric electric moped that
consumes energy
so you can have a bubble tea yeah and
those are the classes we're building now
so there's the elite class there's the
coding class learn to code and we will
have this enormous working class of now
maybe one day you'll be able to post
mates through through in artificial
intelligence
we're not there yet someone is still
cutting open the bagel and putting the
cream cheese on it and putting and
handing it off to the guy
maybe we're what 20 years away from all
that being automatic but as of now we
still need actually it seems like we
need the uber world the we need a
growing
unskilled labor which is the not
pejorative sense i mean it in the
economic sense unskilled labor workforce
and why are we importing tens of
thousands of them every month because
that keeps part of that economy going
and people like it i'm thinking about
human behavior and you mentioning like
maybe i'll get to the point that ai
making the bagel or whatever in star
trek you know
captain picard goes t
computer t earl grey hot and then it
just appears in front of them i wonder
about what humans would do if we had
access to that stuff i think people
would gorge themselves to death yes i
think it would
so i think there's a lot of people in
this country that have the ability to
eat whatever they want whenever they
want because they have access to enough
resources to do so and i i don't even
need that much money somebody makes you
know mid five figures and they decide to
use their excess cash to just eat
eat but there's a lot of people who
don't have the money to spend to do that
and so they end up thinner simply by
virtue of not having the ability to buy
the food
what if everybody had the ability to
walk up to something and just be like
entire cheesecake caramel on top extra
whipped cream pumpkin spice
and you could just keep doing it they
would gorge themselves i wonder if
people would just if they really did
have that kind of level of technology if
we reduced the cost to near zero or did
a ubi and we had ai producing everything
i think people would be like wally
they'd sit in chairs and they'd be like
i wash myself with a rag out of stick
yeah you know that would be an awesome
kind of kind of cruel but an awesome
experiment like imagine if you had to
take someone who was willing to you know
they had to work from home you know and
for you're going to live in this room
for a month here's your job blah blah
blah but when you ask for something
you're going to get it
you know just like we we can't do it
instantaneously we need a little bit of
time but like it's lunch time what do
you want to eat it's dinner time what do
you want for dinner it's breakfast what
do you want for dinner
it's movie time what do you want to
watch and you would wonder if after a
day it would be like i want to watch
porn i want to eat this i want to eat
this i want to eat this and you'd love
to know if after the month the person
would come out
dead or if they or if at a certain point
they'd be like i feel disgusting like we
all do that you know like yeah bachelor
party weekend and you're drinking an
open barred even at a wedding but at a
point most of us are like you know what
i'm i'm just can i just have a water
i wonder if people would i'd be curious
to see if you could do it with multiple
folks
how many would just become
that gluttonous disgusting slob you know
five folks from the city and five folks
from the country
yeah you know just just yeah i'd love
i'd love to see i like to think about a
certain i know it sounds like a reality
show we should fun yeah it does yeah now
i know like my i know what my tastes are
and i don't know what i would ask for
but i like to think that by like the
third day i'd be like well i'm not gonna
have dessert again this is brilliant but
would i utopia island
and we take
you know yeah five people from the city
five people from the country
and every morning they can request
anything they want
at all yeah i mean obviously you can't
get a jet the point is in terms of your
living you have access to any food any
entertainment you just have to trick
them as all good sociological all good
experiments do you have to trick them to
think that the experiment is about
something else they can't know it's
about their food choices just and part
of this you can ask for whatever you
want to eat but the the experiment of
the 10 of you on this as you have to
build it's a reality show on this
reality show is something else and they
don't know that
this is this is really the experiment i
i would fund that i think that would be
awesome yeah so i want to know the
results of that i would love to see what
people would we would we
we would tell people like the goal of
utopia island is to perform tasks and do
x and then as an aside we'd say you know
uh put in any order for any kind of food
you want if you have a craving for you
know blue cheese burger onion rings
anything like that you want a steak let
us know and we will get whatever food
whatever entertainment one chef just
because we want people working on the
show to be comfortable yeah i'd love to
see if it confirms stereotypes like
there's the guy from boston always like
lobster and chowder yeah like you know
does the guy like is the italian always
like getting pasta i'd love to know for
like i think confirmed region more than
ethnicity you know like somebody who
grew up
is always getting a cheesesteak
again seriously you have to measure for
them the like if you eat a sandwich and
i see you eating it there might be
something in my mind we're like i want
that and if i smell onions on your
breath i'm like man i want onions you
know that so we gotta you have to
isolate them when they eat and then make
sure you don't smell each other's foods
not at all because otherwise literally
at any time you can ask us for food and
we will get it for you but then they
might not go with what they want just
whatever they see in the moment that's
irrelevant well it might taint the study
why would it take to study because you
don't know what their real choice like
it changes there is no real choice
literally like
when people are in a in a group
when people are on an island that's not
the point of the study the study is we
will give you access to any food at any
time of the day you let us know uh we're
here for you just let us know what you
want literally you name it you want
tiramisu we'll get you tiramisu you want
to you want a whole cheesecake we'll get
your cheesecake just literally tell us
you would be curious to know if like
your tendency is to be healthy like i'm
not going to smell your salad and
suddenly crave salad but like if you
smell my chocolate cake would you
someone be like that smells really good
oh yeah people have chocolate people go
in the fridge and they're like what's in
here oh i'll eat that yeah
so but if you need to control studying
i'm thinking of freezing salad with
cranberry pie nuts and spirulina
there you go i mean i think i think
would you be surprised i think there'd
be a lot of people it's just an exotic
green it's a seaweed and it's one of the
healthiest foods on earth now here's
spirulina it's like an algae isn't it
yeah here's the funny thing could you
imagine somebody comes in like a
working-class person moderately like
average weight and they're like i can
order anything you literally tell us
what you want to eat while you're on the
show we take care of you because so that
you can oh
i'll take a t-bone i'll take a mashed
potatoes and some asparagus he's like
you got it we come back i'll take a
dessert you know you want a dessert
absolutely apple pie ice cream done done
pumpkin spice you know cake carrot cake
or whatever and then by the end by the
end of the month they're like 40 pounds
overweight
i think i think you'd find it i think it
would be curious to see if people would
gorge themselves if they were given
unlimited options or do you have like
the question is does the human
individual have the ability to
regulate itself or is it again we're
back to loch and hobbes or is it the
society that regulates you is it you
looking at me when we have 2 pm check-in
that you're like whoa turning you got a
little chunky there you know like am i
not eating because i see that you see
that i got fat or am i not doing it
because of my own life awareness here's
another idea
we also have a plant who does nothing
but eat non-stop
not slovenly not like right now but just
being like whenever they see him he's
got like you know he's got like brad
pitt in ocean's eleven do you ever
notice i know she's always eating he's
always eating something so they walk in
and he's got like a mac and cheese and
he's like hey how's it going you know
what's been going on and then the guy
walks in he's got a cheesecake and he's
eating and then someone sees it i'll
take a cheesecake too
and then this person secretly is just
exercising full speed
and you know so they're always looking
really good but they're always eating
non-stop we could do it with animals we
could try you know they're like you know
there are certain dog breeds that they
call free feed that people that just
leave food and when the dog is hungry it
will go if i did that to my dogs they
would eat until they threw up they would
eat the throw up they would eat and
that's and they like you cannot have
food around they're very well trained
they wouldn't ever eat my food but but
i'd be curious to see if if if humans
have that like certain dog breeds some
do and so can i can i legally do a
chicken utopia experiment oh so we're
building the new chicken city yeah it's
going to be fully enclosed because we
have a fox yeah and then a hawk just
recently attacked and then roberto went
and then all the chickens ran inside so
we're like okay we'll do the chicken run
we'll do the whole thing covered yeah
you can walk in it but you have to go
through the door
what if we just let them keep having
babies well you know what i'm going to
do i want to get a big huge maybe like
50 gallon food thing that we just fill
up and they just eat the food and the
food comes down and they keep eating it
i think it doesn't spoil so it stays dry
right yeah i've my chickens i have every
now and then gone out and and there's
still food in their bowls because
they're just they like to peck at the
grass and they like to peck at bugs i
don't see them eating to the point that
the food is gone my dogs yes but but my
the point is if we give chickens access
to unlimited food and water and they
keep having babies will it turn out like
the rat utopia will chickens as
different kind of animal be
yeah they're not have a different
chromosome right birds zw or something i
don't know will they will they have a
different reaction to a limited space
but unlimited resources
no
even the racers will fight each other
even your your three chickens that are
too small to be in the public but are a
little too big for like they they want
out because their space is getting small
so yeah they they need if their space is
limited they'll start getting crazy when
they get on top of each other yeah yeah
that's the challenge because we got
three of the babies are fully feathered
now i think they're at seven weeks about
but they're not big enough to be with
the rest of the chickens because they'll
get attacked that's the problem when
they start breeding at different times
that's why you have to control your
roosters you know we can do that all
these different ages and it's too much
we just we let the older ones out of the
enclosed coop and then close the door so
they're in the run and then with the
little ones out in the enclosed section
to run and do chicken stuff
yeah it's a tight space in there for
them because we got we have five black
star babies now they're special special
breed yeah the the girls
every inch of their bodies are black
except one of them has one white feather
what guys that's a big part of the rat
utopia experiment is the lack of space
they're stuck in a space so they have
infinite stuff that might not be a
problem like new york right your space
is limited like earth
we're stuck here right now yeah yeah
people keep trying to go higher but
you're still
yeah you're still stuck yeah if we could
somehow remove that from the study
that'd be interesting stuff
might not be any social issues at that
point i have tried to convince people as
you know i'm i'm
about two hours outside of dc and i've
had a lot of friends come for the
weekend and they talk about how it's
almost therapeutic right i think i think
one of the biggest problems with dc or
new york or any city is that many people
never get a chance
to not live in that when i think of new
york i think of gray like looking
through gray air because it's so dirty
from the i just imagine the grayness of
that city and i think it's the brake
dust and the lack of light
right i mean when you have when every
building is 70 80 90 stories
you you live in the shadows a lot
they're it's very hard to get some
that's why people flock to to central
park there's not a lot of sunlight
especially in the midtown area so
yeah you're just you're surrounded by
huge tall oh new york people people
don't understand it's it's it's tough
it's a tough place it's worth seeing
once imagine an apartment where your
only window when you look out is a brick
wall why because it's within like five
feet of the other building
there's nothing to see outside your
window but a brick wall and you're
locked in there for like a year and
you're paying 4 800 a month for it yeah
people lose their minds yeah it's like
solitary control but they don't know
they're losing their minds that's the
crazy part a lot of times when you're
losing your mind you don't realize
you're losing your mind it's just things
to start to seem you get angry at stuff
you get less little tolerant you know
that's losing your mind that's an aspect
of losing your mind yeah yeah getting
back to that theme that we always return
to people getting mean just wait and see
how mean they are when the prices keep
going up and the scarcity really kicks
into place that's that's when you're
going to see a lot of mean spirited us
just
yeah if if alex jones is right
then i hope you guys are getting out of
cities
yeah done yeah people are just nicer in
the cities and quite frankly when i go
grocery shopping
everyone's got a got a gun nicer in the
city
no no outside of the cities yeah you
know when i go to the grocery store
you know you know a lot of people are
concealed carry and it's just nicer
people are friendlier because they're
they're they're a country folk i'm a big
proponent and like i said i'm a city kid
i'm multi-generation city kid i'm i'm a
becoming a country boy but i
am happier in the country than i ever
could have been in the city it's really
a different lifestyle it's funny when
you're with city people in the country
and they'll point out to you someone's
gun they'll be like oh yeah that guy's
got a gun yeah and i'll be like okay
yeah yeah but yeah he's got a gun and
i'll be like i know half the people here
probably do you can't see him
you mean he's open carrying we can see
yeah you don't need to tell us
well you know i'm not gonna pretend to
be some country boy either i grew up in
the city i've only been out here for a
year i was in um northeast ohio i grew
up in in the suburbs chicago falls and i
kind of always loathed the country
because it was like less technology you
know i like to play video games we'd go
to my aunt and uncle's house in the
country and it was like it was just
boring there was cows you know there
were fields it smelled stinky and there
was nothing to do
for me because i was a city boy but then
i went to the city i loved it then the
internet came out and now it's like
fresh air fresh air is number one yeah
fresh air man i smelled that dank stank
for so long in new york city it started
to destroy my mind i mean
yeah and silence which i think we as a
society have less tolerance for silence
that's why i how many people couldn't
get through the entire uh movie what was
this movie where they weren't allowed to
talk because the aliens
people i know couldn't get through it
because it was just it was too quiet you
know i mean how many people walk with
you you know what amazing when you see
people driving with earbuds in
and and you don't even put on the radio
like it's just people are constantly
certain are younger people and then they
sound like an old folk you young folks
but our younger people are bombarded
bombarded by sounds
non-stop
internet phone music
silence is is is key to any thoughtful
person and you don't find a lot of
silence in the city when we go outside
at night we hear really weird things
those weird bugs yeah yeah it's like
it's it's kind of fun
oh stink bugs are bad yeah they are
get the funny thing is bugs are back i
have the air conditioning on like
invasive species from china
yeah
i have ac on full blast oh i know and
it's like 75 outside and 60 in the house
and they're still trying to come in and
then they get cold and fall to the
ground like the bar existing why are you
coming into my freezing house i don't
understand that it's i guess it's
instinct they go inside
to escape you know for the winter but
then it's colder inside the good news is
chickens absolutely love it i'm just
gonna say that try to catch them and
they play like stink bug rugby you just
like
give it a little shake so he's stunned
oh sorry this is me
throw him down and the chickens
one of those male tubes where you like
put the mail in it sucks it but for
stink bugs from this we can put them up
and send it over
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time